it offended me i was like
why do people think i just couldn't
figure out why people thought that how
to get under khloe kardashian's skin
compare her to her famous sisters i'm
not here to play games coco appears on
the not skinny but not fat podcast and
admits it irritates her when people pit
her against her siblings courtney and
kim kardashian i just think constantly
just the comparisons either with they
want to say like the old me versus what
i look like now or even just comparing
me to my sisters all the time right
because it's like you guys this is what
we look like so i feel like you should
know by now right enough like oh my god
i hear it all the time the good american
founder also sets the record straight on
plastic surgery rumors
people were like i've had like 12 face
transplants i'm like oh my god i have i
was like that's crazy yeah but like it
didn't bother me like it offended me i
was like
why do people think i just couldn't
figure out why people thought that yeah
i've had one nose job right that i love
that like i would don't care to lie
about it nothing but the transplant
thing i was like i just want to
understand why
i don't know anyone could do a face
transplant but that sounds amazing later
in life but this isn't the first time
chloe has reacted to accusations of
altering her appearance
oh no after the 37 year old reality star
appeared in a commercial filmed last
year one troll commented quote so much
plastic surgery and said quote she
looked like an alien in true chloe
fashion she quickly clapped back on
twitter writing sorry you feel that way
you have every right to block mute me
some advice is great but it's also not
what you say it's how you say it it's a
downside of living life so publicly with
millions of social media followers for
years the kardashians have been accused
of altering their photos i think for
every sister we have different boundary
levels remember this pick fans were
quick to criticize coco's feet and
fingers claiming she stretched them out
but chloe fired back and said it was
simply an artistic photography lens to
give the shot a very specific look in
style isn't that crazy
another rumor the reality star thinks is
really wild
like the oj's my dad like but that's so
old but that's my point yeah
you guys have come up with a new thing i
get it chloe's got the right mentality
and when e.t spoke to the reality star
she insisted that she's more focused on
her beauty within
i really think i'm in a good place but i
think working on your personal growth
internally is something that will be a
forever
mission and i always want to evolve and
grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people
[Music]
you